[Musique]
bonsoir il ya trois ans j'étais
directeur commercial dans l'informatique
et j'ai changé de vie assez radicalement
selon certains on me dit parfois je suis
courageux et même des gens qui me
félicitent
c'est pas comme ça je les ai vécus pour
moi ce fut un parcours joyeux un chemin
vers mes aspirations profondes
ce fut une renaissance je me souviens au
début je me suis posé trois questions
quelle idée était vraiment importante
pour moi qui voulais fréquenté et qu'est
ce que je voulais vraiment vivre et je
me souviens aussi de deux étapes très
inspirante et structurantes
c'était en premier la lecture d'un livre
de pierre rabhi nommé la sobriété
heureuse et un film documentaire sur un
philosophe nommé andré gorce
et c'est à ce moment que j'ai compris
que si je change mon comportement
c'est le monde qui change car je fais
partie du monde
chaque geste même le plus petit change
le monde
j'ai arrêté de penser que j'étais pas
légitime j'arrête ai pensé je n'étais
pas compétent j'ai un traitement si
j'étais tout seul j'ai découvert la
jouissance de vivre la cohérence entre
mes actes et mes pensées
j'ai redécouvert mes aspirations
profondes le sens de la vie le partage
la confiance envers les autres la
relation authentique l'autonomie
l'action collective joyeuse et c'est
pour vivre ses aspirations que j'ai
décidé peu après de lancer les colibris
de versailles et depuis avec des
dizaines d'autres colibri nous avons
inspiré lancée initiée réalisé soutenu
plus d'une cinquantaine d'actions et de
projets ok c'est quoi donc ses actions
et projets dont je parle je vais vous
donner quelques exemples dans trois
domaines en particulier
j'ai changé mon alimentation
aujourd'hui plus de 75 % de ma
nourriture me vient de producteurs
paysans que je connais personnellement
un paysan à elle chez un paysan
producteur de blé à la fois meuniers et
boulangers un paysan producteur de biens
paysans producteurs de fruits je les
soutiens activement en leur achetant ma
nourriture un an à l'avance oui elle
avance je le fais au sein d'une
association qui s'appelle une amap
je me souviens au début il ya trois ans
n'était 5,6 aujourd'hui nous sommes sans
famille à versailles et le paysan a
réussi est même devenu un copain vrais
copains il est venu dîner dormir
plusieurs fois chez moi et tous les ans
je veux passer plusieurs jours dans sa
ferme pour lui donner un coup de main je
suis même allé un peu plus loin dans la
démarche
au mois de mai 2016 j'ai lancé le
premier jardin partagé de versailles
avec une vingtaine d'autres versaillaise
et versailles et nous avons le plaisir
de travailler dans un jardin potager
j'ai le plaisir de manger des légumes
que j'ai fait pousser et puis au mois de
janvier 2017
nous avons lancé un deuxième jardin
partagé à versailles deux fois plus
grand 40 familles 1300 mètres carrés en
plein coeur de versailles et plus grands
tout ça c'est qu'avant j'avais jamais
jardin ma vie et puis je me suis aussi
interrogé sur ce que je mangeais par
exemple avant j'adorais le steak tartare
n'en sais rien et j'ai vu des reportages
sur la façon dont étaient fabriqués la
viande rouge est juste quand j'ai pris
conscience de l'impact sur la planète
j'aime toujours tartare mais je peux
plus manger ça fait plus envie
un deuxième domaine où je me suis
interrogé justement c'est mon impact sur
la planète en moyenne un français
produit 250 kg de déchets par déchets
non recyclables
alors comme je mangeais plus de légumes
j'avais des jardins donc je composte ça
ça divise par deux en gros mon poids
poubelle et puis avec une dizaine
d'autres colibri on a réfléchi sur
comment faire pour pouvoir réduire notre
production de déchets et aujourd'hui à
travers différentes méthodes j'ai divisé
par dix je suis à 25 kg par an je mets
mikko pinard concours elle a 10 kg par
an j'ai réfléchi aussi sur comment faire
pour aider les autres donc du coup j'ai
créé un système au sein de la map où les
gens ils viennent récupérer leur panier
et ils apportent leurs déchets de
légumes et ça repart sur le champ du
maraîcher une tonne par an de sauver des
à poubelles et puis j'ai lancé aussi le
premier conte poste de quartier à
versailles puis un deuxième des gens
peuvent venir déposer leur rupture
légumes osenbach après les déchets je me
suis posé question sur la consommation
d'électricité en termes d'impact
et pareil avec une dizaine d'autres
colis breen versailles pendant cinq mois
on a réfléchi sur comment on pouvait
faire pour réduire une consommation des
précités en cinq mois nous avons diminué
notre facture des tris et de 25 % juste
à travers quelques gestes sans rien
changer à notre confort et puis après
ils nous sont posées mais qu'électricité
l'esquirette pas des fournisseurs d'être
is it et éventuellement un peu
renouvelables je les chercher sur
internet
j'ai trouvé un distributeur producteur
des précités 100% renouvelable
ça m'a pris exactement trente minutes
pour faire le changement d'opérateur
tout est pris en charge par les deux
opérateurs
l'ancien nouveau aucune rupture 30
minutes et puis après je me suis aussi
intéressé à ma banque et ce qui aurait
pas des banques qui soit peut-être plus
éthique bête moins d'argent dans des
paradis fiscaux des hiboux est ce que je
veux dire ou qui peut-être sont un peu
moins enclins à faire des des projets
dans le domaine de l'extraction fossiles
je vais sur internet il ya deux banques
qui se dégagent du lot très nettement
l'une d'elles avait une agence à
versailles et j'ai donc changé de banque
un troisième domaine dans lequel je me
suis interrogé c'était ma consommation
j'ai arrêté presque totalement d'acheter
des objets alors certes ça m'a fait
gagner beaucoup d'argent mais surtout ça
m'a fait gagner un temps fou le temps de
réfléchir à ce que j'allais acheter le
temps d'aller comparer le temps d'aller
acheter le temps de revenir le temps de
le déballer de l'installer le temps
d'utiliser l'objet le temps de jeter
c'est juste énorme le temps que je
gagnais pas faire tout cela et ce temps
j'ai fait le choix de le consacrer à
porter mon attention à moi aux autres
et à mon environnement par exemple avant
j'avais une voiture voiture ça coûte
cher sa peau les mes poumons et ça rend
dépendants pétrole j'ai décidé de leur
voiture maintenant l'âge de marche à
pied
j'utilise un vélo du temps en temps j'ai
utilisé transports en commun et j'ai
même grâce à une association de viroflay
j'apprends à réparer mon vélo tout seul
avant j'utilisais exclusivement l'euro
vous savez cette monnaie un peu limité
spéculative peu pérennes aujourd'hui
j'utilise en plus ce soleil c'est une
monnaie locale
ils monnaient durable et conviviale
chaque semaine j'échange des objets des
services
oui ici à viroflay à versailles contre
des soleils je le fais avec d'autres
particuliers je laisse au sein d'une
association qui s'appelle le sel de
versailles système d'échangé local
ok alors parfois quand j'en suis la
raconter tout cela c'était une personne
qui me disaient mais renault comment est
ce que tes enfants vivent cela je
réponds mes enfants ils sont heureux de
me voir heureux un jour il ya même un de
mes fils qui m'a dit qu'il trouvait cela
plutôt fun parce que c'était rigolo et
des trucs variés puis rencontrer des
gens plutôt bienveillant les différents
et puis souvent nous discutons de ces
sujets et de ses concepts nouveaux
concepts qu'ils utilisent parfois dans
leurs études supérieures dans leurs
activités des concepts tels que
ressourcerie ripart café jardin partagé
monnaie locale des concepts nouveaux
tels que débat mouvant forum ouvert
communication non-violente sociocratie
décision par consentement élections sont
candidats
et enfin quand je pense certaines
personnes me disent mais c'est trop
difficile ya trop à faire c'est trop dur
j'avais juste à commencer par des choses
simples des choses sur lesquelles je me
sens à l'aise et en confort de le faire
j'invite pour moi je préfère poser ses
actes à plusieurs ou en groupe
juste parce que c'est encourageant et
conviviale merci
[Applaudissements]